on va passer au premier débat de ce club
on va parler de l'emploi des seniors il
y a quelques jours le ministre de
l'Économie Bruno LEM a annoncé vouloir
raccourcir la durée d'indemnisation des
plus de 55 ans en recherche d'emploi
alors toutes les enquêtes le montrent il
est plus difficile pour un seior de
trouver un emploi Jérôme Rabier a suivi
l'un d'entre eux frappé par le
chômage à bientôt 55 ans Franck buer
peut afficher sur son CV une longue
expérience professionnelle
principalement passé dans l'industrie
mon
CV j'ai un diplôme d'ingénieur j'ai fait
les études en Allemagne tout de suite je
suis parti en Suisse j'ai travaillé dans
une belle entreprise dans le secteur de
technologie j'ai V même changer de pays
changer de culture changer de langu
changer de secteur et je me suis
installé en France euh j'ai pris
l' le poste d'un responsable service
client et j'ai obtenu également des très
beauonsx résultats son dernier poste
dans une PME française s'est soldée par
un licenciement en 2019 à 50 ans et
depuis Franck Buire enchaîne les
déconvenus là vous voyez trois piles de
candidatur sur des postes euh qui
m'intéresse qui sont en adéquation avec
mon profil mais pas que je m'adresse
également à des sociétés à des secteurs
hors de mes de mon premier cercle de
compétences vous avez fait combien de
candidatures au total plus de
1000 il sait que son profil part avec un
handicap un facteur sur lequel il n'a
aucune prise je ne peux pas changer mon
âge je peux changer mon salaire je peux
changer le poste que je vais obtenir je
peux essayer de convaincre à avoir un
discours qui estaétissant qui est
enregissant et valorisant mais je ne
peux pas changer que je perd un petit
peu mes
cheveux en fin de droit Franck buer a
accepté un poste à temps très partiel il
assure le transport scolaire d'enfants
handicapés 2h le matin et 2h
l'après-midi pour environ 400 € par mois
enthousiaste et motivé il ne comprend
pas la proposition de Bruno Lemaire
d'encore réduire la durée
d'indemnisation des chômeurs de plus de
55 ans comment on peut tenir un un genre
de discours et de rendre encore plus
difficile la vie des seiors vous savez
en ce moment je je dépend à 100 % de ma
femme qui a un salaire et c'est c'est
très difficile
d'être d'imaginer le futur Franck buer
n'a pas baissé les bras dans sa quête
d'emploi et est accompagné notamment par
solidarité nouvelle face au chôage une
association qui accompagne plus de 3500
demandeurs d'emploi qui constate la
persistance des préjugés sur les
seigiors les phénomènes de
discrimination il y a des préjugés
relatifs à au manque de malléabilité au
manque de perméabilité aux nouvelles
technologies à la
fatigabilité à la moindre capacité à
s'adapter à des transformation à des
évolutions eux aussi dénoncent les
propos de Bruno Lemire qui met l'accent
sur des indemnités chômage qui
n'inciteraient pas au retour à l'emploi
beaucoup de gens et la plupart préfèrent
travailler y compris moins cher voire
pour l'équivalent de ce qui perçoiv en
allocation chômage plutôt que de ne pas
travailler c'est toute la vision de la
place des seiors en entreprise qui doit
être revue elon l'association formation
temps partiel transmission les chantiers
sont nombreux et ne peuvent se régler en
mettant uniquement l'accent sur la
question des indemnités chômage on voit
cet exemple Nicolas de de cette personne
Franck licenciement en 2019 à 50 ans
depuis des galères un temps partiel
est-ce qu'il y a dans notre pays un
problème avec l'emploi des seniors oui
bien sûr il y a un problème puisque
quand on regarde les statistiques de
l'emploi pour les tranches d'âge les
plus élevé on est en dessous de la
moyenne européenne et donc il y a
clairement une difficulté pour le marché
du travail euh français et de pourvoir
euh de de de fournir pardon aux
seigneurs des des des postes notamment à
à ceux qui euh ont été dans des des
parcours d'emploi euh avec des
successions d'emploi différents et là on
a une vraie difficulté qui est une
difficulté typiquement française et
c'est pour ça ça explique que Bruno
lumer veuille veuille s'y attaquer ainsi
que qu'éliisabeth borne et un sujet pour
eux sils veulent arriver à continuer de
faire baisser le chômage et passer de 7
% à 5 % à ce moment-là euh il y a un
sujet d'emploi des sénors qu'il faut
absolument résoudre alors on le voit au
fil du temps hein il y a un facteur
d'espoir c'est que ce taux d'emploi des
sur il progresse année après années
c'est notamment un effet des réformes
passées des retraites mais ça reste
insuffisant pour rejoindre la moyenne
européenne ouais c'est c'est dû à quoi
pierre est-ce qu'il y a une réticence
des employeurs dans le reportage on
entendait l'association dire qu'il
fallait revoir la place des seigneors
dans l'entreprise c'est ça le problème
aujourd'hui oui mais le problème c'est
c'est presque une vision philosophique
de des âges de la vie c'est-à-dire que
la réforme des retraites on en a
suffisamment parlé sur ce plateau pour
rappeler car à un moment donné quand on
a travaillé toute sa vie on peut aussi
se dire qu'on peut être utile à autre
chose sans être forcément dans un
rapport employeur employé euh toute
personne à partir de 55 60 ans et
grands-parents ou peut avoir une
activité sociale dans des associations
et donc être aussi actif pour l'économie
que d'être employé dans une entreprise
on sait aujourd'hui que le problème
principal c'est d'ailleurs
l'inemployabilité pour un certain nombre
de chefs d'entreprise qui préfèrent
recourir à des jeunes euh profils plutôt
qu'à des profils plus euh euh plus âgés
donc 55 ans qui sont parfois plus
fragiles et en même temps inemployabl
vous prenez des aides soignantes ou des
infirmières qui portent des poids toute
la journée des aides à domicile qui pent
des poids toute la journée qu'est-ce que
vous voulez dire à ces personnesl qui
ont fait toute leur carrière dans dans
ces métiersl qui ont le dos courbé qui
ont des maladies des EAU qu'on on plein
qu' on plein de de de problèmes de santé
qu'on va leur dire il faut continuer à
travailler à porter des poids dans
l'hôpital dans les cliniques dans les
chez les chez les personnels à domicile
c'est c'est ça qui est quand même
problématique il y a à la fois un
problème de de de comment on on sécurise
les les les travailleurs jusqu'à un âge
avancé et en même temps l'obligation
l'absolue nécessité aussi faite aux
entreprises de recourir à l'emploi des
seniors parce que c'est vrai que les
entreprises ne privilégient pas les
personnes les plus âgées alors
qu'évidemment elles sont elles ont des
compétences et des connaissances elles
pourrai accompagner des jeunes qui
rentrent dans le milieu professionnel
enfin il y a tout un tas de choses à
inventer mais le problème c'est que la
lecture de Monsieur le Maire et de ce
gouvernement de l'employabilité des
personnes de plus de 55 ans elle se fait
contre eux c'estd qu'on a l'impression
que ils ont plus de 55 ans ils veulent
plus travailler non c'est pas vrai ils
ont ils ont un parcours souvent plein et
ils arrivent en fin de carrière
effectivement blessés et donc c'est pour
ça que les chiffres des plus de 55 ans
sont de plus en plus importants et de
plus en plus conséquents dans les
chiffres du chômage mais inventons un
autre monde il y a des jeunes qui
cherchent de l'emploi et des vieux qui
veulent sortir de l'emploi pour être
utile différemment c'est ça qui va pas
c'est cette philosophie qui consisterait
à tout à pointer la responsabilité sur
les plus de 55 ans alors qu'ils peuvent
être tout à fait bénéfiqu à la sociétéat
génération qu' voulu franis hand c'est
contrat de génération alors oui il avait
appelé ça le contrat de génération mais
il y a il y a avit pas véritablement
marché non plus c'estàd que les objectif
avait pas été atteint les entreprises
n'avaient pas joué le jeu il y avait pas
suffisamment d'élan et d'entrain et
d'activité économique pour que ça
fonctionne la croissance était restée
assez faible à cette époque mais il faut
être il faut être lucide aussi sur les
métiers qui sont concernés c'estàd que
les personnes qui se retrouvent dans
dans l'emplo dans dans dans dans le
chômage et qui ont plus de 55 ans c'est
pas des catégories sociales
professionnelles supérieures c'est pas
des journalistes c'est pas des
intellectuel c'est pas des c'est pas des
universitaires c'est pas des des
médecins c'est pas c'est pas des avocats
c'est pas c'est c'est souvent des
métiers qui sont des métiers les plus
difficiles des mécaniciens ce sont des
des des des ouvriers ce sont des
boulangers c'est des métiers qui sont
difficiles ce sont souvent ces personnes
là qui retrouvent pas de l'emploi parce
que des problèmes de physiques parce que
aussi un problème d'inemployabilité de
la part de l'employeur donc c'est aussi
la responsabilité de l'employeur et
c'est ça qui est assez insupportable
avec ce gouvernement c'est toujours de
mettre la responsabilité face aux
personnes qui se retrouvent en situation
de détresse de d'exclus sociale et de
chômage principalement alors justement
on va revenir sur cette mesure annoncé
par Bruno l en tout cas sa volonté
d'abaisser la durée d'indemnisation
chômage des plus de 55 ans pour l'
liignée sur celle des autres chômeurs
d'abord si pour qu'on comprenne bien
aujourd'hui quelles sont les règles de
l'indemnisation des seigneurs et
qu'est-ce qu'un seineor aussi la
question seigor c'est une personne qui a
plus de 50 ans selon l'INC quand elles
sont au chômage ces personnes
bénéficient de règles spécifiques car
elles ont plus de difficultés à
retrouver du travail les demandeurs
d'emploi reçoivent une allocation plus
longtemps lorsqu'ils ont 53 ou 54 ans et
encore plus longtemps à partir de 55 ans
si vous avez 53 ou 54 ans la durée
maximale d'indemnisation peut aller
jusqu'à 22 mois et demi à partir de 55
ans elle peut aller jusqu'à 27 mois au
total à titre de comparaison pour tous
les autres travailleurs la durée c'est
18 mois maximum pour les seignors les
bandages vont être relevés oui le
gouvernement donne aus partenaires
sociaux une deadline ils ont jusqu'au 15
mars pour négocier et trouver un accord
sur l'emploi des seigneurs objectif de
l'exécutif créer les conditions pour
arriver un taux euh d'emploi plus
important chez les seniors à horizon
2030 vous l'avez dit tout à l'heure
Nicolas la France est sous la moyenne
européenne en la matière l'exécutif veut
changer tout ça et il met la pression
écoutez qu'est-ce qui justifie qu'on a
encore des durées d'indemnisation
différentes suivant qu'on a plus de 55
ans ou moins de 55 ans c'est une
hypocrisie totale c'est une façon de
mettre à la retraite de manière
anticipée les plus de 55 ans le plein
emploi d'ici à 2027 c'est le cap fixé
par Emmanuel Macron 5 % de chômage c'est
le plein emploi aujourd'hui on est
autour de 7,4 % il y a encore du boulot
ça passe selon le gouvernement par un
alignement on l'a entendu de la durée
d'indemnisation des différentes
catégories de CH de chômeurs Bruno Lom a
aussi voulu donner un tour de vis aux
dépenses de la CQ en gros aujourd'hui le
gouvernement dit au syndicat négocier
comme vous voulez jusqu'en mars mais
n'oubliez pas qu'à la fin c'est moi qui
décide est-ce que Bruno Lemire a raison
Nicolas de dire que le plein emploi
passe par une réduction de
l'indemnisation chômage pour les plus
alors ça passe sans doute par euh
certaines mesures celle-ci et d'autres
et ça passe d'abord parce que c'est
l'élément principal par une croissance
économique soutenue c'est l'élément qui
permet de réduire le chômage partout
c'est mathématique il y a pas plus
puissant qu'une croissance économique
soutenu pour créer des emplois donc ça
c'est c'est l'élément principal et ça a
été d'ailleurs le le le l'alpha et
l'oméga de de la politique d'Emmanuel
Macron depuis son élection c'était aussi
la politique qui était déjà recherchée
par ses prédécesseurs donc il y a rien
de de de très nouveau autour de de cet
axe là après effectivement il y a sur le
marché du travail on a parlé des seiors
on peut parler aussi des jeunes des
éléments qu'il faut sans doute régler un
peu différemment pour les adapter à la
conjoncture économique la logique mais
qui est celle de l'assurance chômage
c'est de faire en sorte que la
protection soit plus forte quand la
conjoncture va mal et puis qu'on qu'on
qu'on libère un peu les choses quand la
conjoncture va mieux la difficulté pour
le gouvernement en ce moment c'est que
la conjoncture va un peu moins bien donc
vous pouvez avoir un discours plus
libéral qui est logique et qui
fonctionne quand on est dans des
périodes où la croissance est bonne et à
partir du moment où ça ralenti ce qui
est le cas en ce moment c'est un peu
plus difficile de l'entendre après sur
le point spécifique des seigneors dont
parle Bruno Lemer pourquoi est-ce qu'ils
ont une durée du chômage supérieure aux
autres c'est parce que les partenaires
sociaux on consid dirrait que c'était
plus difficile de retrouver du travail
quand on avait au-dessus de aujourd'hui
disons 55 ans et ben cette situation
c'est un peu une spirale infernale parce
qu'à partir du moment où vous dites que
les gens n'ont pas une possibilité de
retrouver du travail que vous laissez au
chômage plus longtemps ça se transforme
en une espèce de prè-retraite et d'après
le gouvernement il y a des situations
d'abus de personnes qui qui qui vont se
faire licencier en négociant un départ
avec leur employeur pour ensuite pouvoir
parce que c'est possible c'est permis
s'inscrire à leur assurance chômage et
se faire une espèce de de prèretraite
personnelle bon cette situationl elle
n'est pas quantifiée enfin moi j'ai pas
vu de chiffr précisément mais évidemment
si elle existe il faut absolument la
traiter parce que elle n'est pas très
juste et c'est ce que dit brun mer lui
il dit qu' qu'il envoie un message
positif au seigneur Pierre et il dit on
a on a besoin de vous on a besoin de
votre expérience mais le fait d'avoir
une longue durée d'indemnisation ça
pousse comme le dit Nicolas c'est une
manière de les mettre à la retraite
anticiper il veut lutter contre ça mais
son obsession à Bruno Le Maire c'est
d'être le ministre qui aura réduit le
plus le chômage et ils ont commencé à
réduire le chage obession quand même ça
dépend comment on s'y prend parce que
comment ils ont commencé à réduire le
chômage en mettant le maximum de gens en
apprentissage en formation et qui retiit
les effectifs des chiffres du chômage
donc effectivement plus on on sort les
gens du chiffre chage sans les installer
dans l'emploi l'emploi durable et
l'emploi un peu sûr évidemment on arrive
à faire baisser les chiffres du chômage
je trouve ça assez marrant de voir
Monsieur le Maire aujourd'hui nous
expliquer qu'il veut créer un contrat un
contrat qui qui pourrait permettre à des
gens DEP plus de 55 ans d'être
réemployés dans des dans des contrats à
80 % payer 90 % ça va coûter de l'argent
et d'ailleurs dans le même temps lui qui
disait dans le JDD il y a quelques
semaines ou je sais plus quel journal
dans quelques semaines qu'il fallait
siffler à la fin de la sortie la la fin
de la la tribune Ctait la tribune diche
pardon j'ai fait ou là dans la tribune
dimanche il sifflait la la la fin de la
récrée en disant qu'il fallait arrêter
il fallait serrer les vis de de de
dépenses publiques et aujourd'hui il
nous explique qu'il va falloir plus de
flexibilité à l'échelle européenne pour
justement financer ce type de contrat
qui ne me semble pas être les plus
adaptés justement à à la problématique
des des seiors les seiors sont ceux qui
sont le plus longtemps au chômage il
faut s'interroger pourquoi c'est quel
type de métiers qui sont concernés je le
disais tout à l'heure c'est souvent des
métiers manuels qui sont difficiles donc
peut-être il faudrait envisager des
reconversions ou des accompagnements
vers d'autres fil d'autres secteurs mais
encore une fois on a aussi une vision
très très marchande très
très très productive presque des des des
individus et encore une fois un une
personne âgée qui va être bénévole dans
une association ou qui va aider ses
petits enfants qui va garder les petits
enfants peut être tout aussi profitable
bénéfique à la société que d'être
réemployé dans une entreprise là où un
jeune pourrait prendre un emploi ça
paraît baigné de sens j'aime pas cette
expression j'ai dit baigné de sens alors
je supporte pas il y a pas de sens
chacun son propre sens ce que je veux
dire c'est que çaî logique une forme de
logique à dire faisons privilégion
plutôt l'employabilité des plus jeunes
plutôt qu'à vouloir absolument en fait
le gouvernement est en train de de de
mettre des rusines sur sa réforme des
retraites c'est il a bien compris
qu'aujourd'hui problème de réforme des
retraite c'est plus on va mettre les
gens tard à la retraite plus il va
falloir les occuper donc les 5 ce sujet
il avait été identifié dès la réforme
des retrait puisque le gouvernement a
demandé au patronat et au syndicat de
s'entend de trouver des des solutions
d'inventer des des moyens de de
permettre à cet emploi des seurs de
progresser ce sujet était quand même
identifié Conn ilit mieux s'occuper
d'abord de l'employabilité de tout le
monde avant de s'occuper de la réforme
des retraites qui aujourd'hui est un
véritable problème et un véritable
cass-etête sur les 55 64 ans 65 ans 66
ans qui va être la le taux de départ
l'âge de départ à la retraite attendez
ce que décideront éventuellement
syndicat et patronat qui se sonont donc
il sont autour de la table qui ont 3
mois pour pour en discuter et faire des
propositions et à la fin il y a des
person savoir ce qu'ils vont proposer et
à la fin comme disait Steve il y en a
qu'un seul qui décide et justement on va
en parler de C qui décide Bruno le ma on
va dire un motussce que parce qu'on en
sait pas beaucoup vous voulez parler de
la loi pacte ouais ça on a compris que
vous en saviez pas beaucoup non mais il
il y a des mesures pour entreprise il
est sur une Lig pour entreise oui alors
faut rappeler déjà la loi pacte
qu'est-ce que c'est c'est une loi qui a
été adoptée en 2009 l'idée c'est de
simplifier la vie des entreprises et
effectivement Bruno leire a annoncé la
semaine dernière une loi pacte 2 qui
devrait être présentée en début d'année
prochaine alors ce qu'on sait c'est
quand même les les les premières
orientations du gouver ement Bruno Le
Maire a accordé un entretien à no
confrère du Parisien il s'agirait
notamment de réduire fortement le délai
de recours contre un licenciement il est
actuellement d'un an Bruno Le Maire veut
le réduire à 2 mois on va voir ce qu'il
nous dit aujourd'hui lorsque vous
licenciez une personne à recours contre
l'entreprise reste possible pendant 12
mois il est important que les salariés
puissent être protégés mais ce délai est
trop long dans tous les autres pays
développés ces 2 mois cela me semble un
bon délai pas certain que les
partenaires sociaux soient du même avis
voilà on voit une ligne très pro
entreprise un risque de brouille avec
les partenaires sociaux est-ce que Bruno
le mer fait du Macron il fait un peu du
Macron quand même alors il est dans
cette situation d'avoir potentiellement
une deuxième loi alors c'est pas à son
nom on appelle ça la loi PAC mais c'est
quand même lui qui était à l'initiative
et et à la réalisation de de la première
cé un peu le cas aussi avec Emmanuel
Macron à son époque 2015 il fait la
première loi Macron et puis ensuite il y
a en discussion la deuxème loi Macron
qui deviendra la la loi crerie je je
refais pas l'histoire mais bon on peut
voir un petit parallélisme et puis
surtout la volonté pour Bruno le mer de
poser sur la table des des idées qui
sont un peu disruptives qui font causer
et qui mettent un peu la lumière sur sur
son ministère et sur lui-même bien sûr
parce que c'est ça l'objectif final et
c'est toujours cet objectif là en en
politique et donc cet objet de
négociation autour du du contrat de
travail on peut pas savoir vraiment si
il ira jusqu'au bout en tout cas ce qui
est sûr c'est que les partenaires
sociaux n'accepteront jamais en tout cas
côté syndical d'aller d'aller jusque là
il faudrait aussi que puisse être
identif itif qu'il y a vraiment un
problème spécifique sur cette contest la
façon dont on conteste les les
licenciements là encore il y a pas à ma
connaissance de chiffres très précis
là-dessus j'espère me tromper donc Bruno
leemerire il a c'est pas le la première
idée qui met dans le débat ces dernières
semaine on voit qu'il est dans une
stratégie de de positionnement un petit
peu en décalage par rapport à à l'image
de bon élève de la macronie qu'il avait
jusqu'ici il avance ses propres options
c'est sa stratégie individuelle ça lui
permet d'exister au-delà de de de
ministère de de l'économie d'engranger
des points et on voit dans les sondages
d'opinion que il a plutôt une bonne côte
il est l'une des personnalité préféré
des Français sur le plan politique alors
il reste loin derrière Édouard Philippe
mais en tout cas il est dans une
situation aujourd'hui de pouvoir faire
valoir sa propre ses propres idées de se
faire entendre à un niveau peut-être
qu'il avait jamais atteint je dirais
depuis la primaire de de 2016 des
républicains et du coup il se fait taper
dessus notamment par Marine Le Pen
pierre incapable de créer de l'emploi de
relancer l'économie Bruno Lemer accuse
désormais les seineors d'être
responsablebl de ses échecs elle est-ce
qu'elle cherche à à à retourner la
politique de Bruno Lemer à son avantage
pour apparaître comme la défenseur des
travailleurs et est-ce que Bruno Le
Maire qui on le rappelle a renoncé à
aller au législatif dans son département
de l'UR où le Ren a fait un carton
est-ce que c'est pas un mauvais point
pour lui pour la suite je sais pas si
c'est un mauvais point mais en tout cas
vous avez raison de rappeler que tout ça
est aussi un jeu et c'est dommage que
qu'on l'appelle comme ça communément
mais un jeu politique
euh sur le plan économique Marine Le Pen
et Bruno leemire convvergent sur bien
des sujets Marine Le Pen comme bien
d'autres de ses amis à l'échelle
internationale que ce soit my en
Argentine ou vilkers au Pays-Bas ils ont
un programme l'extrême droite française
a un programme ultra libéral qui
consiste pas du tout à aider les plus
pauvres d'entre nous qui consiste plutôt
justement à supprimer comme semble
vouloir le faire my en Argentine vous
savez avec sa tronçonneuse on va couper
les dépenses publiques parce que ça
suffit les assistes et cetera Marine Le
Pen elle refuse quand qu à l'Assemblée
nationale il est proposé de d'augmenter
les salaires ou d'augmenter les minimas
sociaux elle refuse de voter ces texte
là il faut arrêter de se dire que
l'extrême droite aujourd'hui serait la
voix qui porterait les demandes et les
et les aspirations populaires donc
Marine Le Pen et Bruno Le Maire ont des
convergences communes sur les questions
économique ça n'est c'est absolument
indéniable Marine Le Pen jamais elle
mettra des des des des des contraintes
aux entreprises pour les questions
sociales les questions écologiques Bruno
le mer ne le fait pas plus c'est-à-dire
qu'aujourd'hui on demande aux
entreprises de faire plus d'écologie
plus d'insertion des personnes en
situation handic plus de personnes au
belà de 55 ans mais il y a aucune
contrainte qui pèse sur sur ces
entreprises là donc il y a pas
véritablement il y a une compétition
politique mais en vérit en vrai Marine
Le Pen sur le plan économique vaut assez
assez fortement ce qui la macronie alors
moi je vois pas du tout les
choses avec cette lecture non évidemment
pas vous avez le rassemblement national
héritier du Front national qui est très
étatiste beaucoup plus étatiste que les
Bruno leemer qui est d'inspiration
libérale d'une inspiration libérale
évidente et on l'a évoqué il y a il y a
quelques instants et et et et l'extrême
droite alors il y a une autre partie
d'extrême Dr qui est beaucoup plus
libérale mais ça c'est plutôt côté
Zemour même si on peut les catégoriser
tous les deux d'extrême droite ils sont
pas forcément entre Zemour et Le Pen les
mêmes options économiques donc sur le
plan européen évidemment ça n'a rien à
voir puisque le le cadre européen tel
qu'il est défendu par Bruno Le Maire et
par le gouvernement il tend plutôt par
une forme de de fédéralisme je mets des
guillemets parce que il y a bat s
mantique assez violent autour de cette
question alors que le rassemblement
national et dans son ensemble d'un
nationalisme qui exclut toute
coopération poussée à l'extérieur des
avec l'extérieur des
fronti c'est le cadre d'exercice des
entreprises pour Mo les
de les deux pour
moi néolibéralisme c'estd c'est pas
moins d'État c'est plus d'État au
service des puissants il nous reste 3
minutes on va parler de ce qui ser sera
sûrement la phrase de la matinée une
phrase qui risque de faire du bruit elle
est signée Gérard Larcher interrogé dans
la matinale de RTL sur Jean-Luc
Mélenchon salgne ses déclarations le
président du Sénat n'y'est pas allé de
mains morte on l'écoute c'est
irresponsable quelqu'un qui a des
millions d'abonnés sur X et qui se
comporte de cette manière qui en quelque
sorte par sa parole crée un brasier qui
peut enflammer diviser qui montre du
doigt une de vos consurs on voit bien
avec quelle allusion derrière et bien je
dois dire que c'est inacceptable et
c'est inacceptable pour moi Jean-Luc
Mélenchon s'est mis en dehors de l'arc
républicain vous lui dites quoi ce matin
tu es toi oui ferme ta gueule ferme ta
gueule c'est c'est c'est direct on n'est
pas habitué à ça de la part de Gérard
Larcher il y a ça exprime quoi le ralbol
de Jean-Luc Mélenchon on voit sur son
visage un petit rctus de satisfaction
quand même au président du Sénat parce
qu'il a osé prononcer ce mot cette
phrase pas l'habitude de l'entendre dans
ce registre en tout cas pas publiquement
et c'est vrai que de la part de de ce
personnage institutionnel on s'attend
pas à ce qu'il y ait cette forme de
d'expression qui est quand même voilà
qui est pas qui est pas au niveau de
l'institution qui qui représente il me
pardonnera de de de de de dire ça après
il exprime sans doute ce que beaucoup de
monde autour de lui et parmi la
population française pense de ce que
fait et ce que dit et des positions de
Jean-Luc Mélenchon ces dernières
semaines et voilà il a il a exprimé
peut-être s s'est fait le porte-parole
d'une grande partie de la population on
voit que Jean-Luc Mélenchon est désavoué
on voit dans dans les enquêtes d'opinion
donc quand il s'exprime ainsi Gérard
Larcher ne prend pas de risque en
réalité Gérard Larcher qui connaît bien
Jean-Luc mélenchot on rappelle qu'ils
sont arrivés aux scène ensemble il y a
une quarantaine d'années maintenant ils
ont tous les deux été très jeunes
sénateurs est-ce que un un président du
Sénat peut dire ça pierre ça alors j'ai
oublié le nom de de ce philosophe mais
j'ai j'ai lu un livre qui qui est
fascinant qui s'appelle médiocratie et
je trouve que ce que l'on a entendu ce
matin sur cette antenne de de radio
révèle assez bien ce qu'est l'état de
notre panel politique la médiocrité qu'
les incarne et je trouve assez dommage
et dommageable pour ceux qui écoutent
ceux qui voient la vie politique se
dérouler euh d'en arriver à ce type de
formule en même temps est-ce que ça
exprime pas le fait que Jean-Luc
mélenchau a franchi certaines lignes je
suis souvent agassé sur ce plateau j'en
suis pas à dire à mon contradicteur des
propos aussi désobligeants ce que je
veux dire c'est que il y a des des
accords politique qui doivent être
assumé et c'est bien qu'il soit assumé
il y a des outrances du côté de Jean-Luc
Mélenchon il y a aussi des outrances et
des des des questionnements qui doivent
être interrogé de la part de Monsieur
Larché moi ce qui me choque le plus dans
cette séquence c'est que Monsieur Larché
a décidé que Jean-Luc Mélenchon était
sorti de l'arc républicain ça pour la
peine moi je trouve que c'est un c'est
un c'est c'est une forme d'outrance
c'est une forme de banalisation parce
qu'il dira pas la même chose de Marine
Le Pen elle est pas sortie de du de
l'arc républicain voir elle y serait r
rentré elle y serait rentré en tout cas
ça pour moi c'est un fait politique
majeur que de considérer que Jean-Luc
menchan est sorti de l'Arque républicain
et je pense que c'est une forme
d'outrance comp tenu de ce qui'est le
programme de Jean-Luc Mélenchon cont
tenu de ce que l'on caricature Jean-Luc
mélchon qui vient de sortir un livre
quand même il faut faututut je veux bien
qu'on fe fasse la vie politique sur sur
le compte Twitter mais il y a il y a une
vie en dehors de Twitter ser bien qu'on
s'intéresse à cette vie là aussi r très
rapidement est-ce que les outrances de
Jean mélenchonent cond dis à des
outrances inhabituel he de la part de
gérardch oui je je pense aussi mais
c'est le cas de de tous les extrêmes les
extrêmes ont pour particularité alors
pardon de faire un peu de théorie
pendant 3 secondes mais les extrêmes ne
vous obligent à prendre position les
extrêmes vous empêchent d'être neutre et
de rester dans une pondération et une
modération qui devrait être celle de
tout débat républicain où on s'écoute où
on prend en considération les arguments
des uns et des autres une déogracie
mature qui manifestement est pas le cas
de la France et donc quand Gérard
Larcher a cette expression évidemment il
va sur un terrain très émotionnel qui
est celui d'habitude des extrêmes mais
il il est en quelque sorte contraint de
le faire parce que ces extrêmes poussent
le bouchon tellement loin que elles
obligent les les le champ de la
modération à réagir
ainsi